- Hey, Quinta, how was your weekend?
Quinta, hey!
Hey, Quinta!
- Oh, I'm Heaven.
- Oh.
So how was your weekend?
- It was cool, it was chill.
- Hey, girl, I love your new haircut.
You get your hair cut?
Or is it a weave?
You guys call it a lace front,
right, is it a lace front?
- [Woman in Back] This
coat rack is such a mess.
Look at this.
- [Co-worker] It's so ratchet.
- Can I touch it?
- No, nope.
Nope, no.
- Hey, I think Obama is doing great.
And I'm not saying you're here
because of Affirmative Action or anything.
- So, Martin Luther King Day is coming up.
You got anything planned?
- Do I have anything planned?
- Uh, for the office?
- I've see all five
seasons, well, I've seen
three seasons of "The Wire" and...
- Why would you think that
I was the one planning the
Martin Luther King program?
- Uh, I just assumed it because you, uh...
- Hey, Tracy, have you seen Quinta around?
- Hey, are you guys going
to that company banquet
down at the Richardson Plantation?
- It's at a plantation?
- I'm not racist, I just
want you to know that.
- Wasn't think that.
- It's just been a bad day,
I forgot my glasses at home.
- [Partygoer] It's "Gold Digger!"
- Oh, God, is he gonna say
it, are they gonna say it?
♫ But she ain't messin'
with no broke, broke ♫
- We good, no fights.
- Hey, Quinta, we're going
to go grab some chicken.
Let us know if you want some.
- Hey, Heaven, got I
quick question for ya.
- I'm not Heaven.
- Is he offering me
chicken because I'm black?
Or is he just being considerate?
- Been Tracy for a while.
- I'm gonna, uh...
- All right.
- Have you seen Heaven?
- Have you ever seen Heaven?
- But if I do want some chicken,
do I look like a stereotype?
Man, I just want some lunch.
Why does this have to be so hard?
- Aren't you so excited for the potluck?
- Yeah, yeah.
Um, who made the potato salad?
- Oh, I did!
- I'ma go get a hamburger.
- Just basically, I want you to know
that, like, I respect you.
You know?
- Yeah.
Nice to meet you, Shane
- Yeah!
- Tracy, I am so sorry
about the Martin Luther King thing.
I am the worst.
- I'm Heaven.
Heaven, of course you're Heaven!
Oh God.
- What Martin Luther King thing?
- Yeah.
- What's happening?
- Sorry, I don't get mad when
people try to touch my hair.
(laughs)
- Oh, okay.
No.
None of that.